皆さん、夏といえばなにを食べますか
ｱｲｽｩｩｩｩｩ！
（謎の沈黙）
だよな？（威圧
夏といえばアイスを食べると思うんですけども
何個まで食べた事がありますか
僕、自慢じゃないんですけども
中学校の時実家に住んでいまして
大きな冷蔵庫があって
それを6人で使ってたんですけども
冷凍庫の中にはもう入っている物がほぼ決まっていて
冷凍食品か
アイスか
iceかあいすしかなかったんですよ
で、なんか
うちの家族結構みんなアイスが好きで
結構アイスの頻度が無くなる頻度が多いんですよ
なんでもう
気を抜いた瞬間
アイスが食べれないということがしょっちゅうあって
中学校になった僕はどうすれば
アイスを食べれるんじゃないかと思った時
その一日一個っていう制約を無視して
母ちゃんかばあちゃんがアイスを買ってきた瞬間に
家族用に6個入りとかなんで
その6個を全部食べればいいんじゃないかという結論に至って
アイス6個とかを冷凍庫にセットされた瞬間
それをすぐとって自分で6個全部食って
誰にも食べられなくて済むという満足感を得たんですけども
めちゃくちゃ怒られました。
なので僕アイスを食べる量が結構凄いんですよ
あの一つのNA☆ZOがありまして
僕が中学校のころから大量にアイスを食べる中
よく言うじゃないですかアイス食べるとお腹壊すって
そんなことないなって僕は思ってるし、
そもそも皆さんもおなか壊すほどアイス食べたことが
ないと思うんですよ僕。
今回は検証です。
何個アイスを食べるとおなかが壊れるかを
調べていこうと思います。
まぁ一般的な成人男性の値なのでこれがみなさんに当てはまるとは
限らないんですけども
参考にまでしていただけると助かります。
みんながお腹を壊す必要がないんで
その分は、僕がこうしておきましょう。
今回食べていくのはこちら！！！
まぁ、いろんなバニラアイスがあるんですけども
これが僕の中ではスタンダードなバニラアイスだと思っております。
......
えぇ、そんなにあるんだ
まぁ、でもまさに書いてある通り
バニラの王道なので
まぁ、今回このオーソドックスな
バニラアイスを使って
何個食べると僕がお腹壊れるか？
を検証して行きましょう
いただきまぁーーーーーーーーーーす！！！！！
バニラアイスが好きだから
そもそもこの好物を大量に食えるって いう
至極な時間を味わえること自体
最高です！！！
では、いただきます！
(食べ続けるはじめ)
この結果によっては
皆さんが何個までアイスたべていいかっていう
限度がわかるわけですから
アイスたくさん食べたい人はぜひ
参考になる動画だと思います。
一個目終わりました
溶かせば液体なんで全然食べてる感じがないので
まだまだいけます
てか溶けるんじゃない？
二個目行きます！
うん！
うん！×2
うん！×3
うまい！！
(ひたすら食べるはじめ)
あぁ...
バニラっておいしいんですけど味が単調すぎて
たくさん食べるとちょっと飽きてきました
でもまだ入るんでもうちょっと頑張ってみます
うぇ
三個目いきます
いただきます。
最初の一口だけはほんとにうまいんだよな
どんな状況でもおいしいと思う多分
んん～まだなんか壊れる気はしないんだよな
どっちかというと
舌が低温やけどみたいになってきた
あ×3
あ×4
あ×5
あ×6
いやうれしそうな顔しちゃだめだけどｗｗ
ちょっと痛いかもしれないぞ
ちょっと今おなかに違和感を感じた
そして頭が痛いぞ
アイスクリーム頭痛的な奴がきてる
うぇゲッホゲッホ
全部だめじゃんｗｗ
(それでも食べ続けるはじめ)
三つ目食べました
ええ現時点で食べたカロリーは
四つ目いきます
わぁすごいすごい
ヤバい
鳥肌立ってきたぞ
鳥肌が鳥肌が
わあすごいなマジで寒いな
もうちょいねもう全然ねまだいける気がするんですよ
(四つ目食べ終わりました~)
五個め
いただきます
(あの世に行きそうになるはじめ)
ウブルルルゥゥ
ハァ
頭痛い×3
もうカロリー的には今
は食べてます。
じゃあ六個目いきましょう！
まだか...
早くはら壊れろぉぉ
口が痛い
おいしいんですけど冷たいもの食べすぎて口が痛い
はい七個目です
もうカロリー的には2000Kcalを超えてきましたね
じゃあ七個目いただきます
あっ！×３
はい！
はら痛ゥオェェェ
～エンディング～
はら痛い！はら痛い！
はら痛い！はら痛いよ！
終わった
ヤッタァァァ
やばい
歯と頭と口の中と舌と腹が痛いです
ええというわけで
結果的にアイスはまぁ六個ぐらいですね
スーパーカップでいうと六つまで
皆さん食べれますので
アイスクリームおいしいんですけども
食べすぎないようにしましょう
じゃあな
ウゥ